damn that cats in the wild
is cats in the wild
let's jump right in brendan also got in
the ring
while theo was in nashville nashville
yeah
that looks like nashville what was that
nick
so that was brendan cats of the wild
someone saw chappelle
[Laughter]
being broke so
i'm saying it's my fault
i do know where to believe
i'm saying it's my fault
that looks like the same wig snoop dogg
had in baby boy
i haven't seen that shout out to rallo
blast yeah shout out to rollo
great singing by the way rallo bro you
think you're better than us cause you
got out
i'm not out on me i think you're better
well you're jumping right back down
call yeah i'm here in person oh i
thought it was a hologram
i thought we stepped the budget up it's
a hologram dude i don't know what it's
like over there there i am right there
they found me and rogan fighting i guess
[Laughter]
rogan's actually an unlockable character
but someone created theo oh yeah
that's hilarious dang dang dog and you
were you were crying
uh online like a buckle bunny about
dustin poirier making more money
oh dude they got to pay him uh they
painted by tony ferguson
anybody dude every these guys out there
you know giving out they're giving it
all
you know they giving it all dude some of
these guys they got to rearrange their
face to even smile
yeah you know to even whistle yeah it's
a [ __ ] and here i am telling to pay the
man right here
the diamond don't want to take the fight
that he don't want the fight man y'all
know good and that man never turned down
nothing give me your hair looking crisp
man never turned down a fight
yeah lined up boy catch a uh that boy
will
go outside in december with wet hair
just to fight a damn cold
man that's facts and y'all need to pay
that man dana
you'll need to split that bag up and pay
that man dana pay that man
hey man yeah that nose is flared up dog
oh cause i got slammed by a woman dude i
got slain right on the beak bro a couple
times
getting beat up huh it's hard out there
man how many you're in a new city three
days a week
three days a week damn i had to take a
week off though bro they bad i mean they
banged me up man the ribs yeah you come
in there you the new guy
yeah like let's beat this f and they
call me the f word call me the n word
somebody did oh damn
they said let's beat the la out of them
yeah let's beat this guy huh let's beat
this little
s p i c they call me let's beat this
little guy
damn beat this [ __ ] yeah this little
japanese [ __ ] somebody called
[Music]
wow
[Music]